les voeux du medef martinique c'était
hier soir et c'est toujours l'occasion
de tâter un peu le pouls des patrons dit
le medef
le mouvement des entreprises de france
son président est avec nous ce matin
dans son caddie bonjour bernard edwards
bonjour à vous et bonjour à tous et à
toutes celles qui nous écoutent
bernard edwards dans vos voeux il ya eu
aussi ce regard dans le rétroviseur 2010
8 heures constat la martinique souffre
de son pouvoir d'achat les consommateurs
mais également les entreprises bernard
edwards finalement il ne lui manquait
qu'un gilet jaune ce matin sur les
épaules
non je pense pas que qu'on peut plus
qu'on puisse faire l'allusion entre les
gilets jaunes et les pouvoirs d'achat
bien que ce soit la motivation
principale de ceux qui manifestent mais
en fait qu'est-ce qu'on le constate une
très forte stabilité et je dirais même
stabilité soutenue pour nos entreprises
au cours de cette année en fin de
l'année écoulée 2018 qui reste encore
plein d'incertitudes
d'accord puisque le coût du travail
reste encore un petit peu en dessous des
coûts de productivité
c'est ce qui permet de soutenir cette
activité on se pose beaucoup de
questions d'autant que l'environnement
fiscal lors du plf et du plfss a été
remise à plat vous êtes le 2018 a quand
même été une année plus que difficile
pas d'opportunité pas beaucoup d'argent
à investir l'absence de dialogue social
d'ailleurs on l'a vu puisque ça a
explosé un peu partout au mois de
décembre
mais je parlais pas seulement de
l'absence de dialogue social l'absence
de dialogue tout court je crois qu'il
faut revenir à cette thématique
il faut qu'on se parle il faut qu'on
dialogue et si on fait référence aux
mouvements des gilets jaunes
je pense que c'est une absence de
dialogue qui a provoqué ce mouvement et
je reviendrai de ce que j'ai d'hier soir
puisque je prie je présume que vous
allez me dire de développer on est en
train de passer de la symbolique du
pouvoir à la mathématique du pouvoir et
je m'explique
la symbolique du pouvoir elle se
manifeste par trois donner la légitimité
du pouvoir ensuite l'autorité du pouvoir
et ensuite l'application du droit
je vous arrête tout de suite bernard
edwards faut parler de quelque chose de
très générales sur le territoire
hexagonal la france dans son ensemble
vous parlez du territoire martinique
ah ben ça s'applique à notre territoire
puisqu'on est jusqu'à preuve du
contraire encore lié de manière totale à
ce qui se passe dans l'hexagone
si on prend applicable harry applicable
ici avoir de trop explique habib sy à
fort-de-france et chocolat le moyen de
s'en sortir c'est encore le dialogue est
pourquoi je parle de mathématiques du
pouvoir il ay à autant de lecteurs des
chiffes qui lie à d'intervenants et je
pense que ça crée une certaine
cacophonie
on ne sait plus de quoi on parle
vraiment quelles sont les solutions et
quelles sont les propositions qui peut
sortir de cette situation un peu libre
et si je croyais qu'on avait multiplié
les instances de dialogue les contacts
les échanges il y à des organisations
représentatives comme la vôtre il y à
des associations qui relaie certaines
choses
les instances sont multipliés pour 300
blessés sont multipliées mais juste
comme je dis est là il faut savoir de
quoi on parle même de nouveaux medef et
la dernière fois que j'ai été votre
invité je vous avais informé que le
medef avait signé avec nos
parlementaires une convention dialogue
m'avait dit pourquoi une convention pour
dialoguer et bien la convention
permettent de bien cerner les
problématiques que l'on souhaite traiter
alors ça marche et cette convention et
ça a marché puisque lors des discussions
du plf et du bfs on a eu en permanence
une dialogue un dialogue soutenu avec
nous pour le parlementaire et on a
expliqué lequel étaient les
problématiques des entreprises notamment
au travers de la tva npr et autres ouais
mais deux côtés vous dites qu'il n'ya
pas suffisamment dialogue là vous me
parlez de cette convention qui
finalement fonctionne ça veut dire que
le dialogue est possible jusqu'à un
certain niveau et puis après plus rien
non non il faut qu'ils soient permanents
uniquement vous avez vu des et les
parlementaires que vous leur avez dit
quels sont vos réponses et pas une fois
qu'on les a vus on a traité le doute le
sujet bien en amont est ce que c'est
difficile pour un amendement
parlementaire de connaître la réalité
d'une entreprise on vient leur apprendre
comment une entreprise fonctionne et
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour qu'elle
fonctionne bien oui mais il n'ya que les
parlementaires qui peuvent être
intéressés par ce dialogue
c'est ce que le maire d'une commune par
exemple gagnerait à savoir comment ça
fonctionne la petite boulangerie deux
situés sur son territoire le le garage
le garage auto ou bien peut-être une
autre entreprise de plus forte taille
on a écarté personnes mais jusqu'à
preuve du montrer du contraire ce sont
nos parlementaires qui nous présente qui
nous représente auprès des instances que
ce soit l'assemblée nationale ou le
sénat
et quant à ceux qui décident au plan
local et communauté d'agglo la ctm si si
si si nous sommes en dire
en contact avec eux mais vous savez lors
ils ont des limites dans leur décision
c'est les institutions qui veulent ça
mais vous savez une entreprise en
martinique ou dans les dom
même si son activité reste dans les dom
elle est soumise quand même aux grandes
décisions hexagonal alors soyons plus
plus direct avec qui aimeriez-vous
dialoguer et sur quel thème davantage
j'aurais aimé reprendre le dialogue
quand même avec la ctm parce que nous
avons un secteur qui en qui qui est mal
et on ne voit pas de visibilité sur le
secteur du btp
les appels d'offres ne sont pas la
commande publique est à l'arrêt donc
j'aurais souhaité au sein du medef on
reprendre ce dialogue avec la ctm
pouvoir en fait comment donner un peu de
visibilité à ce secteur qui est pouvoirs
du roi
pourquoi c'est si difficile que ça de le
joindre c'est passé difficile de les
joindre mais il faut savoir exactement
comprendre la perplexité de ce2 ce2 de
ce secteur qui a besoin d'une visibilité
à long et à moyen terme qui sait
peut-être ça le problème
vous dites que on demande à l'entreprise
d'être au carrefour de tout pourquoi on
vous demande cela ben je vous citer un
ou deux exemples nous sommes aujourd'hui
collector de l'impôt avec le prélèvement
à la source jusqu'à maintenant ce
n'était pas notre problématique
nous sommes aujourd'hui sollicitée pour
répondre aux exigences de
l'environnement
jusqu'à preuve du contraire ce n'était
pas notre problématique et c'est
pourquoi je me suis dit et j'ai
communiqué là-dessus on demande aux
entreprises est au carrefour de tout
mais ne pouvait nous ne pouvons pas être
à tous les carrefours
c'est pourquoi vous demande ça c'est
parce que vous avez le pouvoir financier
je pense qu'on a un rôle social d'abord
est-ce que nous sommes les seuls
créateurs de valeur ajoutée
c'est un cliché ça de dire que les
patrons ont le pouvoir financier dont
les patrons n'ont pas le pouvoir
financier
on n'oblige personne aide patron c'est
une démarche personnelle
donc je crois qu'il faut recentrer
l'entreprise au centre des débats et
qu'elle a un rôle social à jouer mais ce
rôle social quand même rouairoux couvert
ou contient quand même des paramètres
dont il faut tenir compte
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à délimiter
ce les cadres les contours de ce
carrefour
c'est à voir ouais et avec qui vous avez
parlé avec un peu tout le monde puisque
nous avons quand même rôle social dans
la société
les enjeux pour le medef en 2019 ce sera
quoi alors les enjeux bull je me défends
2019 j'en ai retenu 4 il faut quand même
réfléchir de manière très claire ce que
sera l'octroi de mer après 2020 et c'est
maintenant qu'il faut présenter la
réflexion il faut assurer des élections
le 26 mai ça vaut le coup de c'est aussi
ici les mêmes ci a pas d'élection les
lots 3 2 mais reste toujours une
problématique d'actualité
il faut préparer et mettre en oeuvre de
transition énergétique
ça a commencé notre monde en parle nos
transit non mais ça a commencé voyez
bien que sur les hauteurs de toute l'île
les éoliennes commencent à fleurir
d'accord pour savoir quand même ça
avance quand même mais il faut la sueur
il faut il faut la poursuivre
une autre problématique pour les
entreprises qui n'est toujours pas
solutionné ce sont les délais de
paiement c'est fondamental il faut
répondre il faut que le gouvernement
plus de nous donner des réponses claires
les asus des entreprises la législation
existe laïcisation hélène elle existe
mais elle est très limité de mon dernier
entretien avec le préfet
effectivement ils allaient pouvoir
d'ordonnancé si vous voulez la priorité
de certaines dépenses mais n'a aucun
pouvoir pour la déclencher
vous avez des 4 vous avez cité 3g comme
ma vie j'ai pas trouvé le gaspiller mes
oeuvres
ça reviendra hier soir à l'occasion des
voeux lorsqu'on discute un peu après les
voeux du président du medef on a entendu
quelques uns des membres du conseil
d'administration dire qu'il faut que
2009 point mais d'être un petit peu plus
agressif de ne pas subir autant il faut
inverser peut-être la morosité de 2018
être plus agressif vis-à-vis de qui ben
vis-à-vis des d'abord de nous mêmes il
faut qu' il faut pas qu'on baisse les
bras puisque je dis toujours quand c'est
très difficile il faut se mettre debout
et argumentée et quand on vous dit que
c'est impossible il faut encore se
mettre de photos d'eux une deuxième fois
et convaincu le profil type du patron
version 2010 9 ckoi
mais le profil type du patro il n'a
jamais changé il faut de la ténacité et
il faut de l'ambition mais pour que
c'est la ténacité l'ambition puisse
mettre se mettre en oeuvre il faut quand
même une visibilité
c'est ce qu'on en demande au
gouvernement bernard edwards il ya de
jeunes patrons en martinique il y en a
qui a envie de se lancer encore malgré
cette morosité dans notre île il y en a
qui ont envie de se lancer et le medef à
pau mission de préparer tous ceux qui
sont à l'école aujourd'hui de répondre
aux exigences et de faire la
connaissance de l'entreprise notre
projet va s'appeler entreprises academy
on va enseigner aux élèves de par leur
professeur qui viendront découvrir
l'entreprise
certaines données de façon à ce qu'ils
puissent acquérir y ait donné l'envi
d'entreprendre à ses élèves qui sont
encore encore des parents qui nous
écoutent qui sont dans leur voiture qui
amène certainement leurs enfants à
l'école il faut qu'ils poussent leurs
enfants sur cette voie écoutez je pense
que si on veut de l'emploi la martinique
il faut que des entreprises secret merci
beaucoup aux bernard edwards président
du medef
merci d'avoir été ce matin avec nono son
crédit bonne journée merci à vous
[Musique]